Please give a warm welcome to Matthew Dix.
It's 1991 and I'm 20 years old and
I'm driving home from the very first
booty qual of my entire life, and
I am excited because I don't know.
That this is going to also be the very
last booty call of my entire life.
And then it's in that moment of excitement
that the right front tire of my 1976 Chevy
Malibu blows out, but it doesn't deflate.
It disintegrates.
It throws rubber rubber on the road in
a way that I didn't think was possible,
and it takes everything I can to get the
car over to the shoulder and to a stop.
And it's 1991.
I don't have a cell phone,
so I do the only thing I can.
I start hiking up the road to look
for help seven hours later after
giving all of my money to a half
naked mountain man named Winston.
I have a bald tire on my
car and I'm heading home.
When I look at the instrument
panel and I see that I have no gas
and all of the money that I have.
Is in Winston's hand, and it's 1991.
I don't have a credit card.
I don't have an ATM card.
I don't even have a checking account.
And so I take the next exit and I roll
my car into a Getty station, and as I
park the car, I'm angry and I'm sad.
I'm 20 years old.
I'm a McDonald's manager.
I make $7 and 25 cents an hour,
and I'm the richest person I know.
My mother is living on
welfare with my sister.
My father's left 10 years ago, and
the only friend that I have who even
has a credit card or a car that can
make this a hundred mile trip to New
Hampshire is off on some college weekend,
and I can't get in touch with him.
And this was not the plan for my life.
I was not supposed to be this alone.
And so I go into the Getty
Station to beg for gas.
$8 worth of gas is all I need 'cause
it's 1991 and gas is 85 cents a gallon.
And the kid behind the counter
will not give it to me.
He doesn't wanna lose his job and
I offer everything and he says no.
So I go back to my car and my plan
is to wait for the next shift change.
Maybe someone more sympathetic will
take over, but as I climb into my car,
I see my McDonald's uniform crumpled
in the back, and I have an idea.
An hour later, I'm in a
residential neighborhood about
a mile from the Getty Station.
I'm on the porch of a red brick
house, and I'm knocking on the door.
I'm wearing my McDonald's uniform,
the blue shirt, the blue pants,
the blue tie, the door opens, and
there's a man standing in front of me.
And I know at that moment that this
is a bad idea, but it's three o'clock
on a Sunday afternoon, and I'm on his
porch in a McDonald's uniform, and the
only way to get off is to go forward.
So I say to him, my name is Matt.
I'm collecting money for the Ronald
McDonald Children's Charities.
Can you please make a donation?
And this man stares at me like
Stone Hen she does not move.
He's 50, but he might as well be 500.
He is all of the wisdom and knowledge
of the world wrapped into one man.
And I know he knows I'm lying.
And the next words that come out
of my mouth, I don't expect, I say.
My mom died of cancer when I was young,
and my sister has cancer now, and I'm
just trying to do what I can to help.
And he looks at me and points
and says, you stay right there.
And he goes back into the house and closes
the door, and I know that he's calling
the police, and I'm going to get arrested
for stealing money from McDonald's,
which ironically, two years later
will actually happen, but not on this.
Day because he comes back to the door
and he has $20 in his hand, which
is like $20,000 to me on this day.
And he presses it into my palm
and I say, no, that's too much.
And he says to me, my wife
died of cancer five years ago,
and I think this is a really.
Bad idea I had.
And before I know it, I am sitting
on the porch with this man and he
asks me about, my mother died of,
and I say breast cancer, 'cause it's
the first one that pops to my mind.
And he says, what does your sister have?
And I say, leukemia, which
I don't actually know is a
cancer, but I know kids get it.
And he tells me that his wife
Lisa, died of lung cancer.
And that his kids live on the West
Coast and he tells me how she struggled
for two years and how he wanted to
tell her it was okay to go, but he
couldn't, and how badly he felt that
he watched her struggle for so long.
And I sat on that porch and I
listened to him and I prayed.
He wouldn't ask me anything
and I just wanted to get off.
And so finally we were hugging and
I was walking down the walk with $20
in my hand and it felt like poison.
I got to my car and I sat in there and
I remembered how lonely I felt, and
then I felt so stupid and small and.
Because I knew at that moment I
didn't understand real loneliness.
I was a 20-year-old kid with friends
and I was stuck in New Hampshire,
but I had walked away from a man
who was in a tiny house with a wife
that was gone and the kids that were
gone, and he had a loneliness in
him that I would never understand.
And so I put the gas in
my car and I drove home.
But he has always been with me.
I have never left that man on that porch
that day, and I'm hopeful that I'll
never be as lonely as he was that day.
Thank you.